günzburg frühjahr 2016 dinge auf ist 76
jahre alt und lebt seit dem tod ihres
mannes alleine zwei jahre zuvor hat sie
einen anruf von einem enkeltrick
betrüger erhalten
damals erkannte der anrufer schnell dass
die geistig fitte rentnerin den
schwindel sofort durchschaut hatte und
rief nicht wieder an den kopf
und siehe da am 17 april papi
nachmittags kurz nach 3 uhr anruf kriegt
[Musik]
denn dran
kennst du mich mehr und dann hat alles
im kopf habe mir gedacht jetzt habe
jemanden sabine bist du und dann habe
ich sie einfach sabine genannt warum
weiß ich nicht sagt sie ja und dann war
es für mich gar geht's muss sie das
durchziehen
ich würde gerne auf dem kaffee bei dir
dabei schauen da fühlte ich mich freuen
wenn du endlich mal vorbei kommt erstmal
recht gerne ich melde mich gleich wieder
bei dir ja dinge auf nutzt die
unterbrechungen um mit ihrem handy ihren
sohn und ihre schwiegertochter anzurufen
hallo mama hallo herr man ihr müsst
sofort vorbei kommen
sybille ich habe eine n trickbetrügerin
am telefon sie will gleich wieder
anrufen
ja gut aber bereit das war hier wieso
hoffens angelegenheit dass sie als
antwort legen möchte und mir gesagt okay
unterstütze das dann in dem fall
wir haben eine quiz geht oder ob das
funktioniert dinge auf ist nun voll
konzentriert sofort beginnt sie über die
eingehenden anrufe notizen zu machen
du bist du alleine zu hause ja du weißt
doch dass ich niemanden mehr habe hier
in günzburg ach stimmt und sag mal ein
handy wird so was kann ich doch gar
nicht umgehen
da komme ich gleich bei dir vorbei hast
du denn meine adresse
ja die habe ich ich muss vorher nur noch
was wichtiges erledigen ja ich schon in
ordnung
mittlerweile sind ihr sohn hermann und
seine frau sabine eingetroffen
[Musik]
hallo sabine hallo mama ich hab dann
problem was hast du denn für ein problem
ich möchte eine wohnung kaufen und mir
fehlt noch was ja hat sie so getan und
dann haben wir im moment gebrauchen geld
hat sie gesagt ja außerdem geld zu hause
die betrügerin schöpfte keinen verdacht
als in ihr haus gleich von sich aus auf
den punkt kommt sie merkt auch nicht
dass oma inge schon längst die fäden in
der hand hält
ja so zwei- bis dreitausend euro
danke das wäre schon mal gut dann meldet
nicht gleich wieder her dass die zeit
also es war ein paar mal nette anrufe
von der anruf pause habe ich von meiner
mutter benutzt um kontakt mit der
polizei aufzunehmen
habt ihr ein sachverhalt trotz
geschaltet und die haben mir empfohlen
wir sagen da mitspielen und sich
irgendwann kollegen in zivil vorbei ab
diesem zeitpunkt hält in der aufsuchung
per handy ständig kontakt zur polizei
wir haben es mit professionellen
betrügen professionellen dann zu tun
die geschult sind die organisiert sind
die in der regel aus osteuropäer aus
osteuropa agieren vorwiegend aus polen
[Musik]
und man kann das du mir das geld holen
es ist nur eine sache ich bräuchte ein
bisschen mehr wie kannst du denn für
mich abheben
ja ich hab so 14 bis 15.000 euro auf dem
konto
14.000 das reicht das ist wirklich mein
ganzes erspartes mein notgroschen das
müsstest du mir schon zurückzahlen das
kann ich dir nicht einfach so schenken
mag man kurzerhand was machen wir also
bekommen das ganze der blitzüberweisung
gags morgen auf ihr konto
macht er weiß dass du heute noch einen
kredit aufnimmt
aber jetzt drängt die zeit denn und am
ende rutschst du mich ja ich bin dran
also das geht in ordnung da gibt es ja
eine sache ich muss das geld komplett
bis 17 uhr beim notar vorlegen für den
kauf der wohnung gehe es am besten
gleich zur bank und hole das geld
erzählt ihnen aber nichts
ich habe gesagt die busse bahn gehen es
dauerte halbe stunde weil ich sehr
schlecht lauf in dieser zeit habe er
großes braunes koberg moment und mit dem
sie billie hammer zeitungen
zusammengeschnitten
etwa eine halbe stunde lang lassen die
hauffs das telefon klingelt sie wollen
den anschein erwecken user tatsächlich
unterwegs zur bank einerseits war die
bisserl aufgeregt und einerseits dachte
mehr mit dem anschauen wenn die disco
bier aufmachen also bitte schadenfreude
habe apple wenn die den umschlag öffnet
erst nachdem die halbe stunde
verstrichen ist reagierten hierauf
wieder auf die permanenten anrufe ja
bitte 14.000 wir ausgemacht
was war das
klingelt ich schau mal nach drei ja mal
gesagt dass das zivilpolizist ich habe
mir waren uns nicht ganz sicher
weil es hätte ja auch sagen dass die
behinderung operieren und die hose tür
stehen und wir haben deshalb auch nicht
geöffnet ach das waren
der postbote post wurde da hast du auf
gemacht nein also welche scheine hast du
dir denn geben lassen
hauptsächlich hunderte und wieviel
scheine sabine das sind 14.000 euro die
haben mir das in der bank gleich in den
umschlag getan da schaue ich doch jetzt
nicht nach ich muss das aber genau in
eine liste eintragen mit nummern dann
komm her und hol dir dann geld selber ab
du kannst dann nachziehen gut machen wir
so ich melde mich gleich noch mal oma er
die täter versuchen auf mehrere art und
weise sicherzustellen dass das geld
tatsächlich bereit gestellt ist und das
können sie dadurch fragen indem sie die
opfer die nummern der geldscheine
vorlesen lassen und dann anhand der
anzahl der nummern sagen können das
dürfte passen
es ist wunderbar darauf eingegangen
[Musik]
ja hallo ich brauche deine
bankverbindung ich bin gerade auf der
bank und ich habe ein darlehen bekommen
das klappt also ich kann dir das geld
direkt zurück überweisen
das ist aber toll du ich hole meine
bankkarte
warte ich muss die karte suchen warten
noch einen moment hattest doch her
ich hab sie de 5 57 204 aufgibt der
betrügerin eine erfundene ivanova 16 oma
was hast du mir dafür eine nummer
gegeben die stimmt nicht
da ist man natürlich ganz vorn sagt
wieso weiss essen das stimmt nicht schau
mal auf den kärtchen ich sehe halt
schlecht
die zahlen den ja verdammt klein
na gut oma ich melde mich gleich wieder
das ziel der täter ist die opfer kamen
unter druck zu halten dazu wird
regelrechten telefonterror angewandt ja
hallo grüß gott braucht auf thomas
müller ist mein sparkassen
er liegt hier ein blitz überweisung über
14.000 euro für konto vor hat er seine
richtigkeit
ja das geht in ordnung wunderbar
sie können bereits morgen auf das geld
zugreifen das freut mich übrigens das
geld für die sabine habe ich schon hier
meinen alles in ordnung
ja danke alles in ordnung
auf wiederhören aufhören
bahnhof teilweise anstrengend bei ihr
immer überlegen müssen hoffentlich
ferrari minute dass sie die richtige
antwort gibt die täter lassen um ihnen
nicht zur ruhe kommen
ich war gerade beim notar und er meldet
sich gleich bei dir
außerdem kannst du vertrauen so wie du
mir vertrauen kannst ja ist schon in
ordnung
mach einfach alles so wieder im rat fand
ihr verlangt und er heißt braun ja in
ordnung weil ihr sohn ständig mit der
polizei in kontakt steht fühlt sich
immer auf der situation noch immer
gewachsen
ich wusste inzwischen das polizei auch
schon irgendwo ist also ihre sicherheit
gehabt und deshalb war er habe mir das
alles getraut
[Musik]
sie kennen die situation ja alle wollen
ja und was kann ich jetzt tun
ich habe bereits einen kollegen gebeten
das geld abzuholen ja sehr gut frau
fragten sie das geld in einem umschlag
den umschlag in eine tüte und laufen sie
dann zur kirche und wie heißt der
kollege hat ein handy dabei und dem
handy bin ich dann dran dann wissen sie
dass alles was sehr gut so frau hoff
verschwenden sie jetzt keine zeit mehr
gehen sie jetzt gleich los geben sie das
geld ab stellen sie keine fragen gehen
sie danach sofort wieder zurück in ihre
wohnung
haben sie das verstanden ja ich habe es
verstanden und ich mache alles so wie
sie es gerade gesagt haben als ich ihnen
auf auf den weg machen will leute des
überraschend an der tür
bitte
das war eine heikle situation für
familie auf denn sie kann nicht sicher
sein ob nun wirklich die polizei oder
doch die betrüger vor der tür stehen
[Musik]
aber die beamten die vorher mit dem sohn
flynn die haufen in kontakt gestanden
haben können sich ausweisen
der nun folgende anruf erfordert in ihr
haus ganze aufmerksamkeit denn diesmal
stellen die täter eine raffinierte falle
vorliegen welche kollegen sie nicht die
polizei gerufen
nein wieso sollte ich dann brennt ist
ganz bei ihnen
nein sind sie nicht die frau schreiner
den tvv okay dann entschuldigen sie dann
habe ich mich in der nummer gehört
auf wiederhören das habe einfach ja
irgendwie sofort kapiert der stimmt was
das ist tatsächlich der in der regel der
letzte anruf der den tätern die
sicherheit gibt wenn denn ein
polizeibeamter vor ort war dass er das
recht zu die nachbarin abbrechen können
oder im anderen fall die den betrug zu
ende führen können
die beamten besprechen mit oma engel nun
die bevorstehende geldübergabe an der
kirche soll sie die täter in die falle
locken dort stehen meine kollegen
spricht die polizei
sobald der man sie anspricht erfolgt der
zugriff und schiss habe ich schaff's
mitnehmen dann hat es sehr beruhigend zu
mir gesagt auf vertrauen sie uns eben
passiert nichts aber gar nichts und dann
geht alles ganz schnell
mit gemischten gefühlen macht sich immer
auf den weg ich kann sagen in der
speziellen situation war die frau auf
jederzeit in sicherheit da wir von
anfang an mit polizei vor ort waren
natürlich verdeckt und für die täter
nicht erkennbar
[Musik]
in höchster anspannung wartet darauf von
dem kurier angesprochen zu werden
der sondiert mittlerweile die lage also
sich sich erwähnt dass die alte dame
allein ist spricht er sie an
hallo sprechen
auf ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es ist 19 uhr 15
fast vier stunden und 45 telefonate
später hat inge auf sein diesem abend
geschafft sie hätte betrüger erfolgreich
in die falle gelockt
erst am anderen tag ist mir das bewusst
gewesen was sich da abgespielt habe bei
uns aber irgendwie habe ich mich
unendlich über mich freut aber denkt
jetzt habe ich es geschafft weil sie
immer wollte weil sie im kopf gehabt
habe
und wir freuen uns auch mehr angehäuft
die jetzt live im studio ist ich
bewundere ihren mut ihre raffinesse wie
sie vorgegangen sind dazu möchte ich
auch den leitenden kriminaldirektor des
polizeipräsidiums kempten begrüßen
albert müller ist bei uns im studio frau
auf wir haben es gerade gehört
viereinhalb stunden telefonterror ja das
muss ein wechselbad der gefühle für sie
war ja auch ja schildern sie das mal ja
ich war natürlich sehr aufgeregt aber
ich wusste im hintergrund ihre familie
und die polizei durch das konnte ich das
auch so machen und ich hatte immer im
kopf ich will diese betrüger rein gehen
also versucht die einfach mehr
einzulegen und es ist merke ich glaube
das haben sie geschafft wir ja wie sind
sie auf die idee mit den
papierschnipseln gekommen
ganz einfach ich sollte dieses geld
übergeben
auf die band bin ich nie gegangen ist
ein park die zeitungen
zusammengeschnitten und dann da rein und
hab noch liebe grüße draufgeschrieben
fall wenn sie es täten das kuvert weil
es sollte mehr gab es mal eine situation
die ihnen zu brenzlig vorkam dass sie
gesagt hätten ich steige jetzt aus das
ist mir zu gefährlich deshalb eigentlich
gang gekommen weil die gustav jetzt so
viel schutz hinter mir und ich wollte ja
selber diese ganze aktion zu ende
bringen mit der polizei
das haben sie geschafft ja durch die
courage von frau auf haben sie ein täter
ermitteln können festnehmen können was
sagen sie zur rolle selbst dennoch vor
zu spielen
da müssen wir natürlich abraten davon
zum einen gibt es immer gewisses wenn
auch sehr geringes restrisiko zum
anderen empfehlen wir in solchen fällen
aufzulegen und die polizei zu
verständigen